bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde au sommaire ce soir les ibères
files s'invite à l'assemblée nationale
l'opposition somme le chef de l'état de
s'expliquer sur ses liens avec
l'entreprise américaine et c'est ce
qu'il a fait cet après midi l'assument
tout vous le verrez des révélations qui
relancent aussi le débat sur l'
influence des lobbys au sommet de l'état
grand décryptage dans un instant avec
nos invités notre grand témoin ce soir
c'est le professeur alain fischer le
monsieur vaccin du gouvernement avec lui
on va revenir sur la septième vague de
co vide qui déferle sur le pays le pic
pourrait être atteint dans les jours
prochains à quoi peut-on s'attendre à la
rentrée un site et ou contraindre quelle
est la meilleure solution et fut les
nouveaux vaccins sont les nouveaux
vaccins seront utiles efficaces contre
les futurs variés on a plein de
questions à lui poser enfin nos a
franchi ce soir j'aurais niveau d'eau
pour la politique les premières fissures
au sein de la nuque fanny guinochet pour
l'économie les gagnants et les perdants
de la chute de l'euro et puis richard
vers l'est pour l'international l'europe
est-elle prête à faire sans le gave de
poutine voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est
parti
[Musique]
une fuite massive de milliers de
documents internes au premier groupe
mondial de vtc un ministre de l'économie
devenu président qui apparaît comme
l'interlocuteur privilégié de ce géant
américain les hubert files s'invite à
l'assemblée nationale et relance
l'épineuse question du lobbying bonsoir
françois cormier bullygeois et bienvenue
sur ce plateau député renaissance du
cher ancien chef adjoint du cabinet d
emmanuel macron alors ministre de
l'économie à bercy entre 2014 et 2016
exactement au moment où emmanuel macron
rencontre à plusieurs reprises les
dirigeants d'hubert vous allez pouvoir
non seulement nous éclairer sur ce
dossier et pas seulement on va le voir
dans un instant bonsoir pierre
dharréville bonsoir bienvenue à vous
également député communiste des bouches
du rhône membre de la nuque qui réclame
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquêté
enfin bon soir damien leloup ravis de
vous accueillir vous êtes journaliste au
monde c'est vous qui avez signé le grand
papier intitulé révélations sur le deal
secret entre hubert et emmanuel macron à
bercy à partir donc de ces milliers de
documents internes à hubert on va y
revenir dans le détail mais d'abord pour
nous planter le décor bonsoir stéphane
sauriol bonsoir à tous stéphane daquo ce
qui comme tous les soirs si j'ai bien
compris l'opposition crie au scandale
emmanuel macron droit dans ses bottes on
y va
[Musique]
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris rien hier le monde a publié
un article pour dénoncer les méthodes
utilisées par hubert pour s'installer en
france mais le titre absolument sans
ambiguïté on parle bien du ber
simplement dans la une on voit que le
nom d'appareils de manuel da cruz
apparaît à trois reprises puis
démographe qui apparaissent aussi qui
saute un peu aux yeux accords secrets
influence violence bref c'est quand même
un dossier sulfureux qu'on a
l'impression de découvrir l'art faut-il
déduire qu'ils emmanuel macron est mêlé
à un scandale à à lévis qu'ambassadeur
pour un peu de ce qu'on appelle un
scandale à son considère que le scandale
que pour un homme politique commence à
partir du moment où il a fait quelque
chose d'illégal ça n'a pas vraiment
l'air d'être le cas d'ailleurs le monde
reconnaît qu' il n'y a rien d'illégal et
puis s'ils avaient fait quelque chose
d'illégal je pense que on aurait passé
la une sur hubert on aurait fait la même
chose la une sur les z'igues ali il
galère il d'égalité de manuel macron
qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche précisément
ensuite on ne peut pas résumer tout en
un coup et heureusement que
les faits remontent donc à la six ans
mais même à croix été mises de
l'économie donc des longtemps qu'il
oeuvrait pour casser le monopole des
taxis en français installé un autre
service en l'occurrence hubert il
l'avait déjà fait quand il était à la
commission attali ça n'avait pas du tout
marché simplement ce que révèle
l'enquêté du monde sait que en soutenant
hubert il soutient aussi les méthodes de
hubert qui elles sont pas du tout
recommandable c'est donc un ancien
responsable du lobbying de chez hubert à
très haut niveau pour plusieurs
continents qui a donné toutes ses
archives au journal anglais the guardian
parce qu'il en avait ras le bol il
voulait dénoncer les méthodes de son
ancien employeur donc en gros ce qu'il
dit c'est que la tactique de hubert pour
s'installer dans un pays c'est de
commencer par violé les lois du pays en
tout cas de ne pas du tout en tenir
compte et puis une fois de lever le pied
dans la porte et que le service est un
peu installé ben il se sert un petit peu
de mode et descendent des changes de 7
cette prise de position sur le terrain
pour négocier des changements dans la
loi pour avoir une base de négociation
donc c'est ce qui s'est passé en france
à peu près autour de lui ce service
hubert pops pas si vous souvenez c'est
un service qui permettait quasiment
n'importe qui de faire un complément de
revenu en devenant le plus low cost
c'est celui qui a traité les violences
des incidents avec les taxis et donc on
a eu peur s'en servaient pour dire si
vous voulez partir ça va falloir quand
même vous donner quelque chose en
échange sont des révélations
embarrassantes pour le président ou pas
c'est sûr que ce genre de papier qui
donne du grain à moudre aussi bien à la
nuque ps qu au rassemblement national
donc sa balle embarrassé un peu je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il était en isère ils
auraient préféré qu'on interroge sur ces
6 milliards investis pour créer une
usine de
semi conducteurs mais je vois cette
personne cette histoire de 6 milliards d
non non ce qui intéresse les
journalistes c'est d'abord la réaction
du président sur l'article du monde et
surtout savoir est-ce qu'il est
embarrassé alors est-il embarrassé
régulièrement comme mes prédécesseurs
il n'a pas prononcé le mot qui rime avec
grenouille monde a bien compris le
message même pas peur cela dit il a
quand même été un peu plus loin en
essayant de se justifier en disant que
selon lui restait il gagna grenier au
contraire en france un climat un peu
malsain des cons on parlait de deux
grandes entreprises multinationales on
écoute on introduit une espèce de
d'ambiance consisterait à dire que 20
des chefs d'entreprise particulier
étrangères ne serait mal mais je
l'assumé à fond et en vous regardant
j'ai vu des chefs d'entreprise étrangers
l'aurore je les ai vu ça a toujours été
officier avec des collaborateurs j'en
suis fier si l'on crée des emplois en
france j'y suis je suis hyper fier de
cela et vous savez quoi je leur ferai
demain et après demain bon en attendant
l'opposition ne se gêne pas pour dire
qu'ils doivent condamner les dénoncer
dire que j'imagine que la plupart des
députés ont lu le monde enfin peut-être
pas à la vingtaine d'articles qui ont
été publiés en 48 heures sur le sujet ça
faisait beaucoup à dire d'un coup mais
ils n'ont rien compris de quoi il
retournait donc aujourd'hui c'était les
questions au gouvernement donc on se
disait cia scandale hubert ben forcément
les groupes d'opposition vont s'emparer
de la question or les seuls qui ont eu
envie de poser une question sur le
dossier hubert ben c'est la france
insoumise pour qui non seulement c'est
un scandale mais en plus ce n'est pas le
premier on écoute danielle simonnet à la
république exemplaire tant vanté par
emmanuel macron après les affaires
mackinsey alstom les sociétés
d'autoroutes et j'en passe voilà le
scandale d'état macron hubert gate pour
s'implanter en france hubert face a valu
des taxis dont mon collègue sébastien de
l'obuts se souvient bien hubert le géant
américain de l'évasion fiscale de la cad
notre modèle social a pu s'appuyer
largement sur son vrp en chef emmanuel
macron et quelle est la réponse du
gouvernement alors isabelle borne a
laissé la parole à olivier grégoire avec
sa grosse voix pour tenir tête aux
insoumis c c est le minimum est donc
comme la meilleure défense c'est
l'attaqué elle a dit plutôt que
d'accuser emmanuel macron de complicité
ou d'avoir soutenu dans son intérêt et
hubert voyons plutôt ce que pendant son
premier quinquennat il a fait pour
essayer de limiter l'emprise des grandes
plateformes américaines en europe voilà
son argument qui a porté qui a porté la
régulation des géants du numérique en
europe la france madame simonet qui a
porté la nécessité de ne pas abuser des
données personnelles la france quel est
le pays qui a proposé en premier madame
simonet une taxation des géants du
numérique la france madame simonet quel
est le pays qui a payé pour cela
sanctionné par le président trump la
france madame simonet alors oui le
président de la république aujourd'hui
ministre de l'économie hier a pris
toutes les mesures pour encourager
l'arrivée mais aussi la protection de
nos consommateurs on a interrompu oui on
arrive bien que pour les uns il ya
scandale pour les autres ce n'est pas le
cas s'il ya une commission denquête à
l'assemblée ben ça sera l'occasion
d'examiner cela plus en détail mais en
attendant c'est sûr qu'il ya débat merci
merci pour ce tour d'horizon très
complet ce soir stéphane j'ai commencé
par les politiques et puis on ira sur le
dossier qui est très complexe avec vous
daniélou dans un instant bon j'imagine
que vous allez me dire beaucoup de bruit
pour rien enfin françois comme les baux
dijon mais vous vous étiez aux premières
loges vous avez vu défiler vous les
dirigeants d'hubert entre 2014 et 2016 à
bercy ça vous pouvez nous de confirmer
et surtout est-ce que ils sont venus
sans au fond avoir ni françois hollande
ni le premier ministre de l'époque que
ce soit manuel valls ou bernard
cazeneuve non mais vous voyez bien que
c'est un pétard mouillé qu'on essaye de
faire une montagne d'une taupinière un
ministre de l'économie rencontre des
acteurs de l'économie
j'ai dit à quelle surprise
voilà c'est ça dossier se font que des
rencontres mais bien sûr le ministre de
l'économie a reçu des acteurs
économiques des chefs d'entreprise des
partenaires sociaux pendant les deux ans
où il a été ministre et il a fait en
sorte que la france puisse être de
nouveau une terre d'accueil pour les
entreprises pour des investisseurs afin
de créer de l'emploi il rencontre avec
allanic en personne le pdg fondateur
d'hubert entre 2014 et 2016 pourquoi il
agit seul pourquoi françois hollande dit
qu'il ne l'a jamais rentrer est pourquoi
on a l'impression qu'il prend au fond
langue avec je parle vraiment être déjà
des rencontres avec des interlocuteurs
sans que le gouvernement soit au courant
et même contre l'avis du gouvernement
mais si le président de la république
doit recevoir à la place de ses
ministres tous les acteurs de leurs
portefeuilles ministériels alors dans ce
cas là il ya plus besoin de gouvernement
il faut seulement un présent de la
république donc il était pleinement
ministre de l'économie il a assumé sa
charge ministérielle et il a reçu
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise oui
pendant deux ans et d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'acteurs de ce dossier des transports
des taxis évidemment hubert mais enfin
d'autres acteurs le cab chauffeur privé
mais également les représentants des
taxis parce qu'il s'agissait de quoi il
s'agissait de libéraliser un système qui
était basée sur des rentes les rend
d'ailleurs de profitant par au taxi
parce que c'est un métier très dur très
noble et que nous respectons et que nous
soutenons mais des rentes qui étaient
aux mains de sociétés de taxis et donc
il s'agissait à la fois de
l'extension de la plateforme et berne al
anon il s'agissait de créer de l'emploi
pour les jeunes notamment des jeunes des
banlieues ceux qui sont exclus du marché
du travail donc leur offrir une
possibilité de gagner leur vie à travers
un emploi mais aussi d'améliorer le
service des taxis lesquels d'entre nous
n'ont jamais pris un taxi hubert
lesquels non je suis sûr qu'on pourra
regarder et qu'on trouverait ça sera
peut-être les prochaines les prochaines
révélations hubert ibérique si vous n'en
avez jamais utilisée pierre dharréville
adhésion au fond des sujets mais moi je
vais vous dire à travers tout ça on a eu
les macronix en 2010 est favorisée par
les russes là il y a des nouvelles
révélations tout ça c'est un pétard
mouillé
chacun sa formule alors pétard mouillé
je peux vous dire aussi une tonne de
mousse avec un gramme de savon ça fait
gabriel at-elle bon vous avez entendu le
langage fleuri chiraquien du président
de la république reprend les grands
auteurs il a cité pour quelques heures
mais franchement le fait de recevoir des
dirigeants suis là dessus ça n'a rien
d'anormal non mais je pense que le fonds
soit comme billie jean présente les
choses sous un jour qu'il arrange un peu
ce que j'ai moi cru comprendre mais ça
nous sera confirmée sans doute ou
peut-être pas par par monsieur leloup
c'est que tout ça se faisait surtout à
l'insu du premier min du président la
république du rapporteur de monsieur
thévenoud dunois à l'époque qui avait
trait à ces sujets là bon c'est ça qui
quand même
moi je vais vous dire d'une certaine
façon je suis quand même pas surpris je
suis pas surpris que emmanuel macron
soit intéressé par le fait de promouvoir
le modèle économique et social
de travail low cost dumais on a ça rien
je combats
lui le promeut jeu mais pas le cas il
avait cette phrase dès 2017 dans la
campagne hubert emmanuel macron personne
ne découvre qu'il ya voilà la volonté de
promouvoir ce type d'emploi je ne vais
pas interdire hubert ce serait renvoyé
les jeunes de banlieue sans
qualification sans trop de la drogue à
stains avait-il dit sur un avantage
militaire quelle caricature un nouveau
quelle caricature mais surtout l'idée
que finalement ces jeunes de banlieue ce
qu est la seule chose qu'on peut leur
proposer cdd sans pas low costs un
véritable droit
vous voulez une commission denquête oui
pour pour enquêter sur quoi parce que ce
modèle des plateformes et des
travailleurs précaires vous pouvez le
combattre mais là on est sur des
révélations qu'est ce que vous voulez
chercher ce que ce qu'on veut comprendre
c'est qu'elle a été la stratégie de
pression
d'hubert pour essayer d'obtenir à la
fois peut-être qui sait un certain
nombre d'avantagés fiscaux 2 aussi
davantage juridique on en modifiant la
loi ou les règlements ou en faisant
adopter des propositions de lois qui les
sécurise juridiquement d'ailleurs une
des lois que nous avons adoptée moi je
je n'ai pas voté dans la dernière
législature d'un dernière ligne droite
visait à sécuriser je connaissais
absolument rien d'illégal à ce stade ce
qu'on écrit les journées du monde à
partir des documents des chutes d'hubert
on est d'accord là-dessus priori non
mais je pense que le sujet soulevé
mérite une commission denquête le
parlement doit savoir exactement comment
fonctionnent ces entreprises et ces
lobbys et qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que
ça a provoqué pour mesurer aussi
l'impact fiscal et l'impact juridique là
moi je vais vous dire ce que ça pierre
moi je vais vous dire ce que ça a
favorisé le chômage des jeunes était à
plus d'1 2 % en 2017 il est à 15 9% en
2022 voilà ce que ça a favorisé le
chômage en général était à 9 6 % en 2017
il est à sept mois des chiffres
quand même écouter le journaliste qui a
signé cette enquête si vous savez pas ce
que vous nous confiez pas un débat sur
les travailleurs des plates formes non
ces métiers là c'est un débat sur les
révélations nom d'albert l'ex enfin
c'est un débat sur comment on favorise
le plein emploi c'est ça le vrai dès
mardi et c'est ça
révélation daniel juste une chose si
vous me permettez c'est pas un débat sur
comment favoriser le plein emploi c'est
un débat sur comment favorise les grands
patrons des grandes multinationales
c'est aussi un témoin sur la
transparence et le fonctionnement des
institutions en face j'entends
travailler
je me permets juste un tout petit point
la question pour moi c'est pas tellement
est-ce qu emmanuel macron le rencontrer
des grands patrons bien sûr quand on
glisse de l'économie je peux rencontrer
des grands patrons et ça fait partie de
sa fiche de poste des questions qui se
posent à notre sens c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils rencontrent avec une
fréquence qui est quand même extrêmement
étonnante un grand patron en particulier
dans le secret le plus total quinté
rendez vous ne sont mentionnés sur son
agenda officiel ses collègues du
gouvernement l'ignorent et ses rendez
vous essayez discussions parviennent et
une forme d'accord entre une entreprise
privée et le ministre de l'économie on
peut l'approuver et pensé que c'était
quelque chose qui allait dans le bon
sens et qui a permis de lutter contre le
chômage on peut le critiquer en pensant
que c'est un mauvais accord avec une
nouvelle entreprise mais de fait nous il
nous semble en tant que média que ce
genre d'accord doit être rendu plus
banal à l'eau ce mot d'accord il peut
être questionnés donc je voudrais qu'on
essaye de pour ceux qui nous regardent
vraiment aller au bout de ce mot là vous
parlez d'un deal secret me paraissait en
titre 1 c'est qu'ils sont sous titrées y
ait une raison très
satisfait que c'est le mot que les
employés du beurre utilisent eux-mêmes à
plusieurs dizaines de reprises dans
leurs échanges en termes il perdit madec
mâcon on a préparé pour qu'on arrive à
suivre parce que c'est assez précis et
technique un petit échange de sms en
fait emmanuel macron va prendre un
décret et je peins sous votre contrôle
qu'il favorise les règles qui
s'appliquent à über notamment sur la
formation les heures de formation va
être considérablement réduites c'était
250 on passe à 7 heures à la suite
justement du bras de fer qui a expliqué
très bien stéphane sur hubert pop la loi
thévenoud l'interdît il ya on a préparé
une petite capture d'écran 3 juillet
2015 suspension donc d'hubert pop et il
ya cet échange entre travis canonique
qui est donc le pdg et fondateur de
l'entreprise est ce qu'on peut faire
confiance à case case étant on va voir
s'afficher l'ancien premier ministre
bernard cazeneuve emmanuel macron répond
nous avons eu une réunion hier avec le
premier ministre cazeneuve cazeneuve
fera faire taire les taxis et je
réunirai tout le monde la semaine
prochaine pour préparer
la réforme et corriger la loi casa a
accepté le deal points fin de citation
est-ce que vous pouvez commenter cet
échange là cet échange intervient
effectivement au terme d'une séquence et
d'un centre de réunions et de
discussions qui aboutissent
effectivement à cet accord vous se dilue
comme l'appellent les légendes du beurre
ou même en échange du retrait du beurre
pop qui est je le rappelle quand même un
service illégal et l'époque en france et
qu beurre persiste à opérer en violation
de la loi et d'ailleurs quelques jours
auparavant deux de ses principaux
dirigeants en france ont été placés en
garde à vue en raison de faits qu'il
continue de doper bsca une stratégie
agressive du groupe qui continue à
mettre d hubert pop dans certaines
villes alors coachée pour interdire
légalement alors que s'il y avait pu
avoir une vague ambiguïté au début là
c'est clair c'est tranché le service est
illégal ils savent très vraisemblement
qu'ils vont devoir l'arrêter parce que
là les perquisitions se multiplient les
gardes à vue aussi et du cou aux rumeurs
tire parti de sa proximité de ces
relations de travail avec emmanuel
macron et son cabinet pour demander
quelque chose en échange de l'arrêt du
service et c'est ça que c'est à ça que
fait référence cet échange françois
cormier beau les gens là dessus au fond
est ce qu est ce qu il est envisageable
que ce soit au fond la pratique du
beurre on a vu dans d'autres pays il ya
des difficultés les perquisitions les
saisies la difficulté d'arriver à
l'interdiction concrètement sur le sur
le terrain est-ce que ce décret peut
être directement en lien avec la fin
réelle de cette super pop de ces
applications là vous voyez bien tel que
vous décrivez j'essaye de comprendre que
vous essayez de comprendre mais vous
avez félicitations très large de
d'emmanuel macro qui dit qu'il ya eu
manifestement un arbitrage
interministériel et que cet arbitrage va
aboutir à un décret c'est donc fait au
vu et au su de tout le monde et donc là
on essaie de réécrire un peu ça veut
dire que
l'aval de la tutelle est
évidemment il ya toute une part de
cuisine qui est fait avant mais comme
vous avez fait une magnifique enquête
journalistique vous ne l'avez pas fait
en plein ciel et vous la rendre publique
une fois qu'il ya des fêtes eh bien nous
il y à des travaux préparatoires qui
sont fait des réunions
interministérielles un arbitrage du
premier ministre et un décret qui est
fait et qui paraît au journal officiel
rien n'est secret d'un dedans et puis
après je vais vous dire il ya eu la loi
croissance et activités ça a été la loi
la plus discutée quasiment de l'histoire
de la république la loi macron dix mille
amendements discutés dans l'hémicycle
emmanuel macron a été là de la première
à la dernière minute en commission
spéciale de la première à la dernière
minute au bond dans l'hémicycle il a
répondu à tous les députés et la loi a
été adoptée tout ça c'est fait donc pour
vous il y avait déjà la transparence
avant ces sites mais c'est la plus
grande transparence puis je vais vous
dire c'est bien mal connaître bercy
notamment à cette époque là que de dire
que tout ça se faisait dans le plus
grand secret à bercy le ministre qui
était le plus élevé dans le protocole
c'était michel sapin un très proche du
président la république françois
hollande et franchement je suis
surveillé de près et donc ce qui rentre
et qui sortait de bercy était connu de
la part de tout le monde donc au fond
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on a on a une
succession de polémiques qui sont là il
m'a kinsale le stade de france a eu
maintenant hubert et c'est une
succession de polémiques qui ont pour
objectif quoi de délégitimer ceux qui
gagnent les élections et d'essayer de re
légitimer ce qu'ils perdent les
élections et au fond toute cette
succession c'est à dire
estimé ray les gens guidon et les
élections puissance actuelle dans notre
démocratie qui de s'attaquer à la
démocratie représentative et de faire le
lit du rassemblement national ce n'est
pas vous qui le faites c'est cette
ambiance de polémique incessante est
totalement stérile qui doivent prendre
fin parce que nous nous voulons lutter
contre le chômage nous voulons lutter
contre la délinquance nous voulons
lutter contre le coc vide nous voulons
lutter contre l'inflation et la vie
chère nous voulons aussi aider nos
frères ukrainiens mais nous ne pouvons
pas passer notre temps à faire ça et à
lutter contre les polémiques stériles
parce que comme ça a été dit très
largement dans cette émission rien
d'illégal dans cette affaire c'est un
pétard mouillé
rien d'illégal certains je suis pas
procureur je suis pas
agent deux agents de police par contre
il me semble que c'est une série
d'événements qui touche à notre modèle
social au fonctionnement de notre
économie notre société notre monde
politique qui était resté secret jusqu'à
présent il a fallu effectivement
l'intervention d'un lanceur d'alerté qui
a pris de grands risques personnels par
ailleurs pour lever un coin de voile sur
alors évidemment l'activité du beurre en
france mais aussi dans une bonne
douzaine d'autres pays et je pense que
c'est une série d'histoires qui mérite
d'être racontée et qui intéresse un
grand nombre de français rappelle
d'ailleurs koscienly l'ensemble
l'article il ya aussi les tentatives du
bear de faire d'autre d'accord ou
d'autres avancées par exemple ces
chauffeurs routiers en faillite que je
libère m et retransformé racheter en
chauffeur vtc ça n'a pas abouti ou la
dgcrf par exemple vous pouvez poursuivre
la répression des fraudes la concurrence
qui elle fait pression par des
perquisitions donc on voit bien que
hubert n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas tout ce
qu'ils aimeraient avoir auprès d'
emmanuel macron quand bien même on n'est
pas dans les temps les situer dans les
documents très compliqué à l'époque mais
il pèse plus byrne ne respectent pas la
loi à l'époque aussi donc effectivement
ils ont une perquisition un moment tous
les quinze jours dans le coup alors que
les sms témoignent du fait qu'ils
aimeraient bien avoir un petit coup de
pouce de la part d' emmanuel macron sera
pas le cas parce qu'au fond et il faut
il faut qu on va je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais vous avez donné son
nom il s'appelle marc mcgann c'est un
lobby cyr landais qui a travaillé pour
hubert on connaît depuis hier le nom de
ce lanceur d' alerte à l'origine de ces
révélations c'est donc l'homme qui dit
avoir trop menti et qui veut aujourd'hui
se rattraper thibault et knock
c'est l'histoire d'un repenti marque
magan lobbyiste en chef chez bear entre
2014 et 2016 a décidé de parler c'est
lui qui a livré à la presse les 124
mille documents internes à l'entreprise
qui montre ses pratiques compromettantes
oui l'axé sol et nous avions vendu à un
mensonge ap comment avoir sa conscience
claire si on ne se lève pas contre la
manière dont les gens sont traités
aujourd'hui yves robin frijns un statut
de lanceurs d'alert inédit puisque
l'homme est l'un des principaux
instigateurs des faits qu'il dénonce
aujourd'hui il reconnaît ainsi sa part
de responsabilité et explique son rôle à
l'époque où je passe de qui parlait au
gouvernement pousse est le modèle hubert
dans les médias celui qui disait aux
gens qu'ils devaient changer les règles
car les chauffeurs allait en bénéficier
que les gens allaient avoir beaucoup
d'opportunités économiques une activité
révélé au grand jour qui met en lumière
la place des lobbys dans les décisions
politiques et pose des questions sur la
transparence de ces pratiques quelles
sont les règles depuis 2016 en france
les lobbys ont l'obligation de se
signaler auprès de l'état c'est la haute
autorité pour la transparence de la vie
publique qui les recense
2451 représentants d'intérêts qui sont
aujourd'hui inscrits que peut-on savoir
les lobbies sont tenus de déclarer à la
haute autorité leurs clients leurs
objectifs et leur budget dans le cadre
du répertoire des représentants
d'intérêts quelles sont les limites la
loi n'oblige pas les ministres ni les
parlementaires a déclaré leur rendez
vous avec les représentants d'intérêts
certains rendent public leur agenda et
ses rencontres mais cela n'a rien
d'obligatoire
les lobbyistes non pas à désigner
nommément
personne avec qui ils entrent en contact
enfin quand les lobbys rédige des
articles de lois ou des amendements clés
en main pour le gouvernement ou les
députés ceux ci n'ont pas à être signalé
là encore en l'absence d'obligation
seuls certains députés font la
transparence sur ces pratiques pourtant
courante tiers d'arrivée évidemment
cette affaire elle relance le débat sur
l' influence des lobbys qui soit ici à
l'assemblée ils sont présents et sont
nombreux il ya des règles qui sont mis
en place où qu'ils soient on le voit
dans ces documents qui ont fuité auprès
des ministres directement au
gouvernement est ce que vous trouvez la
législation suffisante aujourd'hui pour
se prémunir au fond d'une forme de
collusion d'intérêts au niveau plus haut
niveau d'abord dé louis visite ici sont
présents ils sont nombreux je pense
qu'ils savent aussi à qui s'adresse un
c'est pas celui qu'ils contactent le
plus c'est moi je ne donne pas suite à
ce type de deux rencontres je lis
parfois dans les
choses on pouvait pas mélanger une
association une organisation syndicale
avec un lobby qui défend des intérêts
financiers non c'est pas c'est pas la
même chose non vous avez
existe il existe des des forces
économiques et financières qui veulent
conserver des acquis en gagner d'autres
et qui se mobilisent qu'ils y compris
d'air ce qui est ce qui est choquant
c'est cette idée qui puisse y avoir des
sortes d'arrangements cacher voilà la
logique de l'arrangement donc moi ça
m'est arrivé dans une commission par
exemple où on avait été sollicitée jeu
je menais une commission sur les
dispositifs médicaux
certains ont demandé à être auditionné
on les a auditionné tout à fait
officiellement ce qui était intéressant
c'est de mesurer justement leur
argumentaire pour pouvoir faire face
donc c'est pour ça que je les avais
auditionné à l'époque et donc c'était
tout tout ça a été tout à fait public
c'était connu c'était dans cete dans les
auditions officiel de l'as de la
commission
pour leur faire droit
alors il ya de nouvelles règles 1 à
l'assemblée nationale pas forcément pour
le gouvernement mais on vient de les
entendre le rôle de la haute autorité
doivent se signaler pour autant
quentin débuté rencontre un groupe
d'intérêts j'ai plaisir à terme un peu
voilà générique est pas obligé de le
faire savoir exactement comme comme ça
se passe avec emmanuel macron quand il
rencontre des chefs d'entreprise à bercy
est ce qu'il faut changer ça mais
d'abord ce qui est intéressant dans
votre petit rappel c'est que la personne
qui témoigne dans ses papiers dit qu'il
a trop menti le lobbyiste bon c'est un
peu lulu la nantaise qui voudrait dire
la messe quoi bon donc ça lui enlève
quelque chose
je trouve qui y perd un petit peu en
crédibilité à vouloir surfer connaisseur
du sujet aux gars se refait pas
l'occurrence d'enlèvement à l'appui de
nom mais pardon en l'occurrence pour
répondre à votre sa bonne foi de
repentis mais c'est pas ça mais c'est
vous voyez bien c'est un peu c'est un
peu si moi je vois bien elle va dire en
tous les cas
libérés après dénoncer mais pour
répondre à votre question pierre
dharréville comme je le fais comme nous
faisons touche comme nous sommes les
représentants de la nation des
représentants du peuple et que nous
avons à légiférer c'est notre premier
rôle que nous confère la constitution en
permanence nous recevons des concitoyens
qui sont ce que vous appelez des
représentants d'intérêts ça peut être
des associations ça peut être des
syndicats
il ya deux choses c'est que - voyez par
exemple je publie tout ce que je fais
c'est simplement les gens qui veulent
savoir qui je reçois il suffit de
regarder ma page facebook je publie ou
mon site internet je publie tout ce que
je fais photo non etc
oui mais est donc tous mes collègues
faire la même chose par contre ce que ce
sur quoi j'attire votre attention c'est
que la suspicion permanente sur les élus
du peuple à la fin elle finit par se
retourner contre la démocratie et nous
sommes à ce moment là de notre histoire
républicaine et moi je vous adore quand
on voit vous diriez que ce genre de
fuites nourrissent un soupçon malsain
qui attaquent la démocratie car madame
nous allons aux aveyronnais 89 députés
du rassemblement national dans
l'hémicycle il n'y en a jamais eu autant
de toute notre histoire alors qu'est ce
qu'on veut on veut que marine le pen
prennent le pouvoir dans ce pays et donc
on veut à chaque fois être suspecté de
tout ce qu'on fait on je suis un député
honnête intègre tout ce que je fais les
mes concitoyens le savent je ma seule
rémunération ma seule rémunération c'est
mon indemnité parlementaire états unis
par exemple damien leloup et les règles
sont très très différentes pour un
ministre par exemple vous avez une liste
d'incompatibilité très précises qui font
que si vous avez travaillé dans telle ou
telle entreprise surtout juste avant
d'être nommé ça n'est pas possible vous
la laisse beaucoup de règles vous avez
jusqu aux états unis au niveau européen
il ya aussi des règles qui sont
notablement plus strictes pour le
parlement européen et pour les
commissaires européens et problème c'est
que une partie des révélations de ces
documents montrent aussi que ces règles
peuvent être contournées y compris
lorsqu'elles sont très strictes donc
voilà il n'y a pas de y'a pas de
baguette magique est par ailleurs le
lobbying c'est une activité qui n'est
pas illégal qui est encadrée et qui doit
l'être et je pense que c'est assez sain
effectivement qu'elle le soit mais elle
n'est pas interdite et vous rendez
compte de l'absurdité de la situation
parce que vous êtes compétent sur un
sujet vous ne pouvez pas devenir
ministre sur ce sujet là et quand vous
avez à exercer une activité une
responsabilité ministérielle vous ne
pouvez plus retourner
vous ne pouvez non c'est pas le
pantouflage le pantouflage c'est quand
vous êtes fonctionnaire et que vous
partez trévise dans le privé mais quand
vous altérez non mais quand vous êtes
comme embêtant d acquérir une compétence
et vous êtes vous allé directement
travailler par exemple la ministre et
quand vous avez vous ne pouvez par
contre on écrire écrire que vous êtes
marqué au fer rouge
regardez monsieur breton qui est
commissaire européen il est commissaire
européen dans un domaine où il a prouvé
sa compétence parce que il a été chef
d'entreprise d'une entreprise qu'il a
développés voilà c'est aussi simple que
ça donc arrêtons dation bien pour vous
les garde fous sont suffisants pour
lever les éventuels points cette année
c'est notre responsabilité à pierre
dharréville à moi et à l'ensemble de nos
codes de nos collègues de dire ce qu'ils
font en permanence moi j'ai un devoir de
vérité de transparence vis-à-vis de mes
concitoyens à des jeux nationaux il ya
des amendements et on l'a vu dans cette
affaire c'est luc bello à l'époque
socialiste très favorable à on va dire
l'économie que permet une aire les
emplois créés
des amendes ou rédigés par les groupes
d'intérêts données clés en main est-ce
que ça ça devrait être systématiquement
signalés ça peut être une piste oui
d'ailleurs ça se fait de plus en plus ce
que des amendements ont été
comme ça a préparé par des associations
par ni en ligne sont syndicale ça se
sache ce signal
je n'ai jamais vu dire effectivement
j'ai rencontré hubert je dépose cet
amendement ça j'ai jamais juin je vous
dis franchement mais c'est ça pose la
question des choix politiques que nous
faisons c'est ça derrière donc il ya la
question de la transparence et moi je
dois dire que quand la presse fait son
travail et bah ça ne bloque à mon avis
aider la démocratie la première chose la
deuxième séquence 8 derrière tout cela
il ya des dans la société des intérêts
contradictoires moi je sais les intérêts
de qui je défends je défends les
intérêts de celles et ceux qui
travaillent je défend pas les intérêts
des grandes multinationales
voilà bon c'est comme ça et donc est
donc à partir de là il ya des choix
politiques que nous faisons à chaque
fois qu'une proposition de loi il ya des
débats qui s'organise il ya des
amendements qui sont déposées et je
crois que l'élite le travail de la
représentation nationale et des députés
c'est de se positionner clairement sur
le fond aussi les pieds addition qui
sont très bien le loup pour pour
terminer ce débat il ya une chose dont
on n'a pas parlé ça fait partie des
révélations qui souhait grainé il ya
aussi un côté feuilleton aussi dans tout
ça vous l'assumez surtout qu'il y avait
beaucoup trop de retard pour tout public
en ce jour une mise en scène aussi dans
la manière dont on découvre les papiers
c'est la première fois sur le monde
d'ailleurs que j'avais découvert comme
ça la photo bref marque magnum a fait a
fait la compagne d'emmanuelle macron par
la suite et des sels de la république en
marche tout en étant à hubert l
organiser des dîners de donateurs tout à
fait il était en fait il a quitté über
il y rester encore quelques mois ensuite
consultant pour über mais plus salariés
et dans cette période l'a été par la
suite il a proposé son aide emmanuel
macron pour l'aider à monter en marché
donc il a effectivement participé à la
campagne comme militant on peut dire
qu'il avait beaucoup de contacts qu'il a
notamment fait des dons à titre
personnel et organiser des dîners
quelques dîners de fun rising via son
carnet d adresses qui était assez fourni
mais là vous voyez la difficulté ça
rejoint ce que disait françois cormier
brillance et que vous y a une fin on
alimente un peu de soupçons se dit s'il
ya cette autre partie très politique
qu'est ce qui n'a pas de la contrepartie
certains journaux comme valeurs
actuelles le titre en est aujourd'hui
question de contreparties seront écrits
nous de trek la revanche pas
responsables de ce qui arrive à l'heure
actuelle on a écrit très clairement que
d'une barre il n'y a pas eu de chose
d'illégal et légale a dit la trouve
ainsi qu'un élément de l'égalité dans le
financement la mise sur la campagne mais
malgré tout je pense que le fait que
quelqu'un qui était un interlocuteur
régulier du ministre de l'économie en
tant que représentant des intérêts de
l'entreprise privée qui rejoint sa
campagne un poste qui essore certes par
un poste dirigeants etc c'est une
information qui a vocation notre public
aussi le mois de la fin donc on voit
bien que finalement il n'y a pas
d'affaires mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est ce qu'a dit mon collègue pierre
dharréville que je respecte et dont je
partage pas mal de valeurs où il dit moi
je défends les travailleurs et pas des
multinationales mais pour avoir des
travailleurs faut des emplois il faut
les entreprises il faut des
entrepreneurs il faut des investisseurs
et donc moi je défends l'ensemble de
cette chaîne doit discuter je veux aller
chez ensuite les noms
et voilà vous reviendrez quelque chose
mais
c'est pas aussi simpliste que vous le
dites merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
sur le plateau des cp on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin il coordonne
la stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement
il est professeur d'immunologie on va
évoquer bien sûr avec lui cette septième
vague de qu'ovide dont le pic pourrait
être attend dans les jours qui viennent
bref on a plein de questions à poser au
professeur alain fischer comme les skis
ce sujet signé marion becker
si on vous invite alain fischer c'est
parce que la france fait face à la
septième vague de qu'ovide cette fois à
cause du variant b15 avec 130 mille cas
par jour en moyenne
le pic de cette vague devrait être
atteint si quelques jours l'hôpital
attend les un pic dans une dizaine de
jours si on vous invite à alain fischer
c'est parce que vous êtes le monsieur
vaccin médecin professeur d'immunologie
pédiatriques et chercheur en 2016 vous
présidez le comité d'orientation sur la
vaccination
alors quand le qu'ovide fait une entrée
fracassante
vous êtes nommé président du conseil
d'orientation sur la stratégie vaccinale
contre le coc vie de 19
le vaccin pour vous celle arme la plus
efficace pour protéger les plus fragiles
notre niveau d'immunité malheureusement
c'est mon cas après quelques mois
lorsqu'on a plus de 60 ans et moins
durable on a une mémoire immunitaire
comme on dit qui est - persistante donc
ce qui est recommandé ce qui était déjà
recommandé de plus plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois aujourd'hui prend plus
d'actualité devant cette poussée de
l'infection qui est que les personnes
âgées de plus de 60 ans d'autant plus si
elles sont plus âgés mais c'est vrai des
60 ans et plus de 80 et les malades et
les gravement malades reçoivent une dose
de rappel maintenant vacciner les plus
fragiles avec une quatrième dose et pour
tomber à 5 se souvint riendeau micron
semble mieux échapper aux vaccins
peut-on estimer qu'ils sont encore
efficaces face à cette épidémie et s'il
n'est pas plus sévères b15 semble aussi
plus contagieux face à cette épidémie
qui n'en finit plus on vous pose la
question alain fischer quel espoir pour
l'avenir les nouveau vaccin bivalent de
pfizer et moderna dont une séquence et
ciblée contre omicron ou ceux de sanofi
et de la société espagnole hypra ces
quatre nouveaux vaccins prévue à
l'automne pour ont-ils enfin nous
protéger durablement du coc vie
bonsoir professeur fisher alain fischer
habite vous recevoir sur ce fait on va y
venir à ces nouveaux vaccins dans un
instant mais je voudrais d'abord qu'on
parle de ce qu'on vit là maintenant
cette septième vague elle est bientôt
derrière nous pas tout à fait on est à
peu près au pic du nombre de cas mais ça
veut dire qu'il va y avoir encore dans
les jours qui viennent une augmentation
du nombre d'hospitalisations
hospitalisation en soins critiques comme
on dit malheureusement de décès que l'on
voit augmenté sensiblement ces jours ci
puisqu'il ya un décalage entre le moment
s'infectent et le moment où entrent dans
les quinze jours qui viennent jours qui
viennent ils eurent encore en
réanimation bon il faut raison garder
c'est pas une pas qui va comme ça a été
le cas dans le passé dans le contexte on
n'avait pas de vaccin par exemple
entraîné une
très très grand nombre
d'hospitalisations mais un peu plus
qu'il n'y en a aujourd'hui il ya environ
à peu près mille quatre cents personnes
par jour qui sont hospitalisés en france
avec un kobe dont 60% en raison du coït
40% en plus ils ont une maladie plus le
coc vide c'est pas négligeable c'est pas
gigantesque n'est pas négligeable et ça
va encore monter un petit peu donc il ya
tout intérêt à essayer de limiter au
maximum les conséquences de cette voie
là aux gestes barrières au masque mais
ça veut dire aussi que le mois d'août ne
sera pas forcément gâchée pour les
français vacances et alors écoutez comme
toujours il faut être prudent les
prévisions les projections que l'on peut
faire on va être dans une phase de
décroissance donc il va s'amorcer dans
les jours et les semaines qui viennent
donc s'il n'y a pas de mauvaise surprise
c'est à dire émergence de nouveaux
variants on peut avoir un mois d'août
avec un une circulation virale qui sera
sûrement pas nul mais plus faible en
tous les cas alors vous parlez déjà
d'émergence de nouveaux variants on va
reparler mais on nous dit pas ou peu
d'échappement immunitaire ou non il ya
un échappement immunitaire partiel avec
ce nouveau b à 5 qu'est ce que ça veut
dire très concrètement ça veut dire que
si on l'a eu une fois deux fois trois
fois de creux vide on peut être
réinfectées
oui éventuellement mais avec un risque
sauf si on est très fragile très malade
un risque extrêmement faible on a offert
une forme grave donc le la réinfection
peut être source de rien du tout ce
qu'on ne sait même pas qu'on est porteur
du virus si on n'a pas été testé ou bien
avec un petit rhume ou un rythme modéré
c'est en règle comme cela que les choses
se passent
pourquoi il existe alors si on voit
émerger des variances et que par
définition ils ont un avantage sur les
précédents sinon on ne verrait pas
images ils ont deux façons d'émerger
l'une c'est d'avoir un taux de
transmission un peu plus élevé donc
capacité d' infecté nos cellules un peu
plus à lui et ce qui est le cas b à 5 et
l'autre c'est d'échapper un petit peu
plus à la réponse anticorps parce que la
réponse anticorps telle qu elle est
induite soit par le vaccin soit par le
variant précédent elle déclenche donc la
production d'un certain nombre
d'anticorps et leur présence à un moment
donné c'est ça qui nous protège au mieux
contre l'infection maladie grave c'est
encore autre chose et donc si le variant
ont fait que ces anticorps ne se fixe -
se fixe moins bien ou pour certains
d'entre eux pas du tout sur le virus
vont être moins efficace ou bleu et
c'est ce qui se passe on a l'impression
qu'on a un nouveau marais variante où
les tous les six mois est-ce que vous
êtes surpris par la rapidité de la
mutation
non non les virus respiratoires et les
virus en généralement face et le très
variable en fonction du virus mais les
dirigeants se trouvent que les
respiratoires les virus à arn c'est un
virus à arn mythe beaucoup parce qu'à
chaque fois que la rn et copier l'enzyme
qui fait le boulot le fait pas très bien
entre guillemets c'est à dire fait des
erreurs et ses erreurs la plupart du
temps sont neutres non pas de
conséquence ou bien sont délétères pour
virus on n'entend pas parler mais une
fois temps en temps ça peut créer donc
des variations des mutations comme on
dit confère un avantage du type de ce
que je viens de vous décrire au virus
il ya des 10 euros et voilà un nouveau
variant probablement dans quelques mois
l'automne hiver risque d'être difficile
on entend déjà dire que nouvelle vague
les huitièmes serait peut-être a plus à
craindre que celle ci
c'est très difficile de répondre à
l'expression d'abord il faut savoir
qu'il ya des dizaines de milliers d'oies
riant qui ont été décrits à une banque
de données mondiale qui s'appelle qu'ils
aident qu'ils les enregistrent c'était
extrêmement près précieux d'avoir cette
source d'informations donc beaucoup dont
on entend en fait pas parler autrement
que par le fait qu'il a été trouvé une
fois ou deux fois chez tel ou tel
personne donc on a un contexte où il ya
énormément de variation virale et une
fois de temps en temps il y en a un qui
prend le dessus
je vois pas pourquoi ça s'arrêterait à 7
ça c'est évident donc le point important
c'est pas de se dire il y aura plus de
nouvelles vagues où il y aura plus de
variance et il y aura des variants mais
prenons toutes les mesures possibles
pour que les conséquences d'une nouvelle
poussée soit la plus faible possible
c'est ce que de cette façon qu'il faut
raisonner
n'est pas mal armé quand même
d'abord il faut respecter que les gestes
barrière c'est très utile ils sont pas
assez respecté aujourd'hui
malheureusement je pense qu'il faudrait
dans les transports en commun dans les
lieux clos mal ventilé les gens portent
le masque vous faites partie de ceux qui
font regretter la cause la stratégie de
la confiance il faudrait que retourner à
l'obligation oui j'aime beaucoup la
stratégie la confiance je pense que
c'est la base de l'adhésion d'une
société à une mesure de sécurité qui
pour l'ensemble mais quand ça marche pas
très bien il faut en tirer les
conséquences et là on peut pas dire que
ce soit un grand succès si les personnes
qui prennent le métro
soit vous lancez un appel oui bien sûr
mais aussi bien vers les pouvoirs
publics ouvrait les yeux il va falloir
revenir à l'obligation pense que j'ai un
titre personnel déjà transmis ce message
après il ya d'autres considérations qui
peuvent intervenir au niveau politique
mais d'un haut niveau d'une évaluation
scientifique et médicale des la
situation je pense que si l'on pouvait
obtenir que non pas 20 30 40 % je ne
sais pas de personnes portent le masque
en lieu clos monte à 70 80 ce serait
bien qu'on crée un cran
les personnes fragiles en particulier
auprès desquels moule nous sommes en
permanence forcément quand on regarde
les chiffres de la vaccination on est
encore loin du compte il ya eu huit à
neuf millions de personnes de plus de 60
ans qui n'ont pas fait leur rappel
il faudrait quoi une nouvelle vague
massive de campagne vaccinale
je pense que les choses sont en train de
bouger les gens ne sont pas du tout là
dedans ça oui et non les choses depuis
une quinzaine de jours parce que les
messages commence à être répétée les
explications telles que celles que
j'essaye d'apporter ce soir et que je
peux bien d'autres font également que
les médecins font les pharmaciens les
infirmiers à porte auprès des personnes
dont elle s'occupe
font qu'il ya une mobilisation et on
voit le nombre de rappels augmenté s'est
pas encore assez mais on est dans une
phase ascendante et j'espère bien
qu'elle va se poursuivre dans les jours
qui viennent parce que la vaccination
des personnes fragiles c'est de ça dont
il s'agit l'objectif n'est pas de
vacciner toute la population c'est pas
le point le point ses protégés contre
les formes graves de la maladie il
faudra la maladie dans plus de 80% des
cas ce sont des personnes âgées plus de
60 ans et puis sont les personnes
fragiles malade donc ces populations là
est peut-être leur entourage aussi pour
les protéger indirectement devrait
recevoir les rappels qui n'ont pas
forcément toujours eu lui-même un
premier rappel pour certains et puis le
fameux deuxième rappel qui est l'objet
dans ton de discussion ce soir je pense
que c'est une mesure utile on sait que
même si c'est pas un vaccin parfaitement
efficace il est très efficace ils
protègent contre les formes graves il
évite d'aller à l'hôpital il sait comme
hermann fictifs il ya une donnée dont on
parle peu alors est ce qu'on la sait
donner c'est la durée de protection du
vaccin est ce qu'on pourrait dire
clairement que ça dure six mois la
protection est dérangeant c'est simple
tous les 6 mois vous allez vous vous
faire vacciner les choses serait
beaucoup plus simple j'ai l'impression
on ne sait même pas si on va passer en
population générale à la 4è doses d'ici
quelques mois si on peut rester à 3
pourquoi ce flou parce que les choses ne
sont pas aussi simples malheureusement
c'est ce que vous avez raison ce serait
idéal de pouvoir dire aux gens de façon
très carrée à tout le monde voilà c'est
comme ça dans six mois on recommence ou
pas bien évidemment sauf que ce qui
change il ya deux paramètres au minimum
qui interviennent le premier c'est que
le risque n'est pas le même en fonction
de l'âge donc si vous avez 30 ans vous
êtes en bonne santé vous avez 85 ans est
bien le la durée de protection que va
vous conférer une de la même injection
du même vaccin n'est pas la même donc on
est obligé de raisonner
quand on était jeune oui parce que la
mémoire immunitaire comme le reste de la
mémoire tuklu
s'effrite avec l'âge on ne s'est très
très bien ça a été montré pour le coc
vide donc il faut répéter les
vaccinations plus souvent pour des
personnes âgées que pour des personnes
plus jeunes ça c'est le premier point
puis ensuite ça varie en fonction des
variants justement
puisque la réponse immunitaire est un
tout petit peu moins efficace elle
risque d'être un peu moins durables
enfants tous les cas un composant un
composant de cette réponse imiter
vont-ils nous protège et combien de
temps faut sinon le nomination parce que
c'est là qu'on on en vient au sujet de
marion becker est la question qui vous
étaient adressées en conclusion ces
nouveaux vaccins il ya deux il ya deux
de type 1 c'est ça je pense je me tiens
les rennais est plus qu'un si
conventionnel adapté aux variants mikron
quelle efficacité
juste avant beaucoup comme je fini
d'essayer de répondre à votre question
précédente on peut quand même dire même
si avec les limites que j'ai indiqué que
ce fax y recevoir un rappel aujourd'hui
c'est c'est l'assurance à 80 plus de 90%
d'un été tranquille de pas de se
retrouver à l'hôpital voilà c'est quand
même pas
vous faire vacciner il allez vous faire
vacciner n'attendez pas ce dont on va
parler maintenant des nouveaux vaccins
par risques de demain les vaccins de
demain donc ce sont des adaptations de
vaccins déjà existants ces vaccins et
rennes que nous connaissons maintenant
très très bien qu'ils ont été une
avancée extraordinaire de la science et
de la médecine qui ont sauvé un très
très grand nombre de vies je pense qu'il
faut le rappeler si imaginons nous
n'ayons pas ces vaccins rapide ça a pu
arriver dans quel état serions nous donc
il faut le rappeler mais ils ont leurs
limites sont pas parfaits donc les
vaccins et rennes et puis aussi les
vaccins comme vous dites plus classique
fondée sur des protéines avec un nature
donc l'idée c'est il ya un double
objectif c'est d'être le plus efficace
possible à l'égard des variants
circulant aujourd'hui donc b à 5 mais
aussi parce que c'est pas suffisant et
on sait pas quelle variante circulera
septembre en décembre que c'est avoir un
spectre d'action du vaccin le plus large
possible contre les différents variant
colin par définition
donc il faut combiner ces deux
propriétés pour avoir le meilleur vaccin
possible donc il ya des avancées et des
vaccins qui sont en train d'être testé
qui vont avoir je le pense des
autorisations de mise sur le marché
normalement devrait être disponible à
partir du mois de septembre il rappelle
dominique c à court terme donc une
première catégorie ce sont des vaccins
et rennes qui contiennent en fait d'eux
des séquences de deux spike spice est
celle enveloppe protéines qui va plus
important pour la réponse immunitaire
donc aujourd'hui on a dans les vaccins
la spike du virus dit hans et strahl
initial car initiale de vaughan donc là
on combine ray vaughan pour moitié et
soit b1 donc le premier au micron qui
est apparu qui a sévi cet hiver soit
peut-être dans un second temps carrément
b à 5 le dernier donc on sait que les
les premières données en termes
d'anticorps on sent là pas plus que cela
parce que ça prend du temps mais les
données l'efficacité clinique etc
montrent que ce type de vaccin en rappel
induit des réponses anticorps un peu
plus forte et plus large donc c'est pas
mal et puis l'autre approche et que les
vaccins protéiques est intéressant donc
sanofi à un tel vaccin qui est un peu
différent parce qu'il sera pour le mans
dirigé contre une seule fight mais un
peu différente hélas pas une bêta d'un
virus qui sévit en afrique du sud mais
qui semble aussi générer de bons titres
de réponse anticorps il ya une très
belle étude française qui était publié
récemment de collègue odile launay il
faut le souligner cette étude montre des
résultats intéressants des raisons et le
vaccin espagnol aussi qui est encore un
petit peu différent va dans le même sens
merci beaucoup professeur fisher des
raisons d'espérer ça fait du bien parce
qu'on a quand même on s'est compris
qu'il fallait acter on allait vivre avec
le virus est probablement mon vieux mais
beaucoup d'autres mais ce à se faire
vacciner merci infiniment vous rester
avec moi parce que c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir jean rémi baudot pour
la politique quand la lutte commence
doucement à se fissurer fanny guinochet
pour l'économie des gagnants et les
perdants de la chute de l'euro et
richard berry est on vraiment presque
passer du jour au lendemain de gaz de
poutine si le coupé le robinet nous
affranchit des voix si bonsoir à vous
trois merci d'être avec nous on commence
avec vous jean rémy l assemblée qui
étudie actuellement le projet de loi
sanitaire ça va vous intéresser
professeur fisher sur le co vida texte
qui divise la classe politique
ainsi que la gauche rappelons ce que
nous disait le ms aujourd'hui la
pandémie est loin d'être terminée petit
rappel des contaminations en france 130
mille en moyenne chaque jour et dans ce
contexte là l'assemblée débat donc d'un
texte qui prévoit notamment un pass
sanitaires aux frontières ou la
prolongation du sida vous savez le cidep
c'est ce système qui permet de collecter
les données c'est celui qui vous envoie
un petit texto quand vous avez fait un
test et qui permet en fait de tracer la
pandémie le texte a connu déjà quelques
séances houleuses pour le moment la
majorité tient j'ai assisté à quelques
séances cet après midi il serait insensé
qu'on ne puisse plus faire de suivi
épidémiologique de kovy de me confier
par exemple ce matin un peu dépité un
membre du cabinet d'elisabeth bornes
alors pourquoi la gauche est vent debout
contre ce texte déjà par principe pour
protester contre la gestion de
l'épidémie par emmanuel macron une bonne
partie de la nuque met aussi en avant un
possible recul des libertés publiques
notamment sur le fameux traitement des
données particulièrement active contre
ce texte la france insoumise dénonce par
exemple est par ailleurs un texte qui ne
répondent pas à l'urgence de l'hôpital
alors c'est pas tout à fait le sujet du
télex mais pourquoi pas par contre
l'opposition profite de ce texte pour
tenter et bien de placer les amendements
notamment pour réintégrer les soignants
mises à pied qui tous ceux qui ne se
sont pas fait vacciner quelques 12000
personnes selon les propres chiffres du
ministère de la santé mais quand on
regarde dans le détail en fait on voit
que cette idée ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de la nuque si elle est elle si
les ailes et fille sont les plus
véhéments sur le sujet où ils veulent
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
les vers sont un peu plus hésitant au
sein des socialistes là encore c'est
très divisés pour schématiser les
ultramarins sont globalement pour les
autres plus tôt contre les soignants
doivent donner l'exemple explique par
exemple olivier faure qui le reconnaît
je cite il y ait un désaccord au sein de
la nuque sur cette question est ce qu'on
assiste aux premières limites politiques
de la nuque alors ça fait plusieurs
semaines notamment chez les socialistes
qu'on anticipe les divergences sur ce
texte un sénateur socialisme en parlait
déjà en s'amusant il ya plus d'un mois
le plus gênant c'est que le sanitaire
c'est le deuxième texte en deux jours où
la nuque s'affiche diviser la question
de la vaccination des soignants n'est
pas le seul sujet rappelez-vous la
motion de censure hier 150 des 151
députés n'eut pas vais signer le texte
sauf qu'à la fin 146 députés l'ont votée
et six députés de gauche ont choisi
donner ce genre là si socialistes et pas
des moindres par exemple valérie rabault
ça serait bien qu'on se fasse moins
remarquée pour de mauvaises raisons riz
et jaune cet après midi un ténor
socialiste aux quatre colonnes pensait
qu'il y aura d'autres tensions à
l'avenir au sein de cette coalition de
gauche alors le sanitaire on pouvait
l'anticiper ce point faisait partie des
points d accord en fait acté lors
justement de la constitution de la nuque
et il y en ad'autres le ps par exemple a
déjà annoncé qu'il ne soutiendrait pas
certaines idées comme la suppression des
stock options la titularisation de tous
les contractuels de la fonction publique
parmi les autres débats on le sait ya la
question du nucléaire la question de
l'europe autant de sujets sur lesquels
la nuque n'est pas sur une ligne unique
alors il ya un député communiste qui me
disait on est tous différent il faut le
vivre sereinement voilà qui est une
manière de prendre les choses quoi qu'il
en soit dans les prochaines semaines
dans les prochains mois l'enjeu pour la
gauche ce sera d'être suffisamment
habile pour gérer ces désaccords sans
exploser pas impossible ça va demander
de la souplesse et de la bonne volonté
qui ceux qui sont deux qualités pas
toujours très bien de distribuer en
politique merci beaucoup jean rey
nibaudeau professeur fisher réintégrer
les soignants non vaccinées dans cette
période de retour du coville ce serait
une faute je pense que enfin sur
raisonne en termes de sécurité nos
concitoyens ce serait donner le message
les gains de la population et des
professionnels de santé dû finalement
c'est pas si importante se vacciner les
profils de santé doivent être comme cela
a été dit exemplaires ils doivent se
marient tout à fait vacciner pour se
protéger eux mêmes ils sont plus exposés
que la moyenne des français mais aussi
ils exposent leurs patients et même si
la vaccination n'est pas pas l'objet
parfait de la protection des eaux de la
transmission c'est un moyen de protéger
les patients dont on attendait vad et
des principes de santé qu'ils protègent
les patients dont il s'occupe donc je
pense qu'on ne peut pas accepter cette
réintégration si je faisais juste
ajouter un baiser rapidement mille 12000
soignants qui sont qui sont dont on
parle le ministère il n'y aurait que 500
infirmiers c'est le texte qui a été le
chic et aider tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle mais néanmoins ça veut dire
que tous les autres en fait ils font des
tâches administratives et de fait c'est
à celle sont ces autres qui sont depuis
peu peut-être rappeler qu'un que
l'immense majorité il soigne en france
ont tout à fait compris cet objectif et
suivent les recommandations est les
autres sujets avec vous ce soir richard
on va parler de l'énergie bruno le maire
l'a dit ouvertement faut se préparer à
ce que poutine ferme à l'automne le
robinet de gaz coupures que l'union
européenne a bien intégré au point de
travailler sur plusieurs scénarii
d'urgence seulement voilà rien ne permet
pour le moment d'être optimiste
effectivement williams parce que la
question posée par les guerres en
ukraine et surtout par le chantage
gazier de blagues mire poutine elle est
bien plus complexe que la fermeture
seulement
du robinet du gaz qui couvrent rappelons
le grosso modo le gaz russe 50 % des 400
milliards de mètres cubes de gaz qui
sont consommées chaque année par les 27
pays membres de l'union européenne parce
qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement de trouver
des alternatives alors les alternatives
c'est là dessus que travail la
commission européenne il y a le gaz
liquéfié américain il ya le gaz de la
mer caspienne en provenance
d'azerbaïdjan du turkménistan il ya le
gaz du qatar c'est émirats que la france
connaît bien le problème c'est qu'il
faut que ce gaz de substitution
répondent pile à la demande européenne
au moment où les pays en auront besoin
c'est à dire que cela va dépendre de la
météo cela va dépendre de l'état de la
demande tout simplement de la
consommation et ce cas va dépendre
globalement de l'état de nos économies
en gros comment remplacer un producteur
sur comme la russie avec un robinet
toujours pleins par des producteurs plus
ou moins aléatoire je prends juste un
exemple vous imaginez un incendie dans
un des quatre terminé aux terminaux
gaziers français il y en a un à montoir
à dunkerque et à fos-sur-mer
tout peut dérailler imaginez une crise
politique avec l'algérie est un grand
fournisseur de gaz et ça devient
compliqué donc la difficulté c'est pas
seulement de prévoir des alternatives ce
que fait la commission avec son plan riz
power ue qui sera opérationnel je le
rappelle quand même en 2027 c'est de
garantir des approvisionnements
énergétiques alors la france a des
stocks des stocks de gaz naturel qui
sont pour l'instant plein à 60 % on
parle de 80 % d'ici novembre mais en
réalité il ya seulement deux piliers qui
sont sûres si on a besoin de plus
électricité c'est le nucléaire dont on
peut augmenter la production à condition
que les 26 réacteur opal soit de nouveau
opérationnels 26 sur 52 m et il y a les
délestages c'est-à-dire dépenser moins
de gaz à l'air en consommer moins et la
sobriété le délestage c'est un mot qu'on
prononce pas encore effectivement alors
vous avec les énergéticiens dont total
ils ont publié une tribune pour appeler
a dû à une certaine frugalité
énergétique mais le mot délestage c'est
celui qu'on utilise délestage ça veut
dire consommer moins et ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire des chaînes
industrielles qu'on arrête ça veut dire
des installations que l'on cesse de
chauffer ça veut dire des liaisons
ferroviaires qui pourraient être
interrompues et ça veut dire aussi
surtout une bien meilleure coordination
entre pays européens parce que
l'équation est en plus compliqué parce
qu'il faut pas seulement que la france
et son approvisionnement en gaz il faut
que les pays voisins 2 européenne les
aussi donc il faut pouvoir répartir la
charge autrement dit on va voir si le
nucléaire et si la moitié des réacteurs
français qui sont arrêtés va pouvoir
pour voir à cela le puzzle énergétique
et complexes ou hier gazprom a commencé
comme par hasard ça maintenant sur le
gazoduc donc north stream 1 le message
était clair le ils peuvent toujours
produire ils peuvent toujours distribué
à bon entendeur
le monde d hyper crise 1 on a
l'impression de wuala de passer d'une
crise d'une crise à l'autre on suivra ça
avec vous fanion termine avec l'euro
l'euro qui continue de baisser il se
rapproche d'une parité parfaite avec le
dollar en clair un euro vaut 1 $ alors
qu'ils en profitent et qui en pâtit
comme toujours il ya des gagnants et des
perdants surtout que c'est une situation
qu'on n'a pas connue depuis longtemps en
2002 alors juste un mot l'euro baisse
tout simplement parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de turbulences malheureusement enfin
richard vient de rappeler sur l'europe
et le dollar fait encore une fois office
de valeur refuge les investisseurs
préfèrent aller sur le dollar plutôt que
sur l'euro avec la guerre en ukraine qui
est près de chez nous qui la crainte
d'une récession très forte alors un euro
qui baisse c'est bien surtout pour les
entreprises qui peuvent exporter vendre
à l'étranger elle le vendent moins cher
face au dollar et donc toutes celles qui
font une grande partie de leur chiffre
en exportant y gagne on pense par
exemple à l'aéronautique exactement on
construit des avions en france donc
c'est c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
airbus on pense aussi à
l'agroalimentaire c'est un super coup de
pouce pour le blé les céréales que l'on
exporte mais aussi notre vin on va pas
arriver bouder notre plaisir le luxe
aussi parce que souvent on façonne nos
produits en france et en europe et puis
on les exportent en asie ou aux états
unis donc évidemment lvmh ou kering vont
en profiter et il ya aussi un revers de
la médaille bonjour toujours la chute de
l'euro alourdie en revanche la facture
de l'énergie et vous l'avez dit on
importe notre notre pétrole notre gaz et
on le paye en dollars et donc les
entreprises qui sont très dépendants des
importations d'hydrocarbures et bien
pour elle la facture flambe c'est le cas
par exemple la chimie pareil pour toutes
celles qui font aussi beaucoup d'un port
qui font venir un certain nombre de
produits des jouets de l'habillement de
l'électroménager d'asie et puis qui leur
vendent en france ou en europe où lé à
l'euro et plus chères elles perdent leur
différence donc c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle pour elle alors comme toujours
en économie bah écoutez le malheur des
uns fait le bonheur désolé pour les
touristes qui partent en tête alors
toulouse la touriste pour eux si c'est
votre cas si c'est votre cas si à tout
hasard c'est pas du tout une bonne la
rentrée blanche se payer donne en
revanche il tâte tran un très gros alors
que l'on vous n'avez qu'à l'arrière
parce que les apports bien ça va leur
revenir un peu moins cher leurs vacances
en france c'est pour bientôt les
vacances pour vous la franchise ans
bientôt bientôt aussi avec un franc
suisse qui est maintenant supérieur à
l'euro à al alami elle va être cher
vernis acquis voilà qui ne perd pas le
nord merci merci professeur fisher
d'être passé par le plateau de lcp vous
êtes le diable quand vous voulez merci à
vous les affranchis c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
tout de suite votre soirée documentaire
ce soir ma femme a du crédit réalisé par
sébastien le belzic sur le système de
surveillance digitale de masse du régime
chinois très belle soirée sur lcp à
demain à demain c'est la dernière
[Musique]